my name is Maya and I am the costume
designer of the superhero city I work on
superheroes I don't know that it gets
any better than that
so the amount of time it takes to design
and build one of these costumes is
anywhere from eight days to three weeks
and I always try and include something
to do with the original I take it very
seriously our fan base is huge and out
of respect to the fans I want to make
sure that I'm doing right by them I
added a little upgrade to your suit so
this is the flash this costume it has
evolved a little bit but I tried to stay
as close to Colleen Atwoods
original concept as I could oh very cool
we've rounded out the Peck area the
fabric had little lightning bullets
printed on a tiny little lightning bolts
and that was from the original we've
added a longer leather piece and we've
allowed this lightning bolt to go from
front to back just to allow a bit more
of a flow to it don't forget this show
is called the flash it's not called the
man in the gray pinstripe suit so the
flash costume is very important Colleen
Atwood set a very high bar there and you
know we're just trying to keep up
this is rivals so the whole idea with
the rival was to have him look like he
was volcanic so his outer layer looks
scorched almost and the idea here was
yeah molten lava nice skirt top the
interesting thing about this costume was
it was a little bit of a special effect
because when she turns skirt flares out
and we get to see the yellow underneath
which is her colors you get that whole
top vibe anything for you baby this is
mirror master sometimes a character is
just wearing clothes they're not wearing
a superhero suit they're wearing regular
clothes like you and I look better we
try and find little subtle ways to
introduce the character so in his case
he's wearing a satin shirt his suit has
a sheen to it his pocket square has a
sheen to it and all of those there to
suggest
mirrors
this is kid flash the flash kid flash
turn out early if I wanted it to look
like you're his shoulder blades and just
to emphasize big shoulder small waist
beyond the question for the first time
was incredible
I just felt like total geek a total
child it's a dream come true I got this
there's that moment when they look in
the mirror and they realize oh my god
I'm a superhero and it's magical this
season there's lots of superhero
goodness coming at you lots of
hey youtubers is Charlie so huge news if
you guys missed it in that video we saw
a full-blown killer frost and vibe
costumes that haven't appeared on the
show yet so this is - a breakdown so if
you missed it in the background they
have a bunch of extra costumes that they
don't talk about they just say you know
couple superhero things gonna be
happening this season at the end of this
video and you see what looks like the
vibe costume with the gauntlets and
caitlin snows killer frost costume which
looks kind of like a mix of a couple
different killer frost costumes in the
comics they are really like three
different versions of the character in
the comics and each of those has had
slightly different versions of their own
costumes
there's Krystal frost Louise Lincoln and
then caitlin snow so if this star looks
familiar
you'll recognize this as part of Louise
Lincoln's costume from the comics she
was in assault on Arkham that was the
version of killer frost in that animated
movie so you can see they're blending a
couple different versions of killer
Frost's costume but they have like the
darker blue leather look of Louise
Lincoln with the star but also the
sleeves in the collar from crystal
Frost's costume so I think they did that
for a couple different reasons like they
wanted to do Louise Lincoln just because
she looks really how like it looks like
a really good costume but because it
doesn't have any sleeves danielle
Panabaker the actress would probably
freeze herself in real life on set
because if you've never been on a film
set because the cameras and the lights
and everything is so hot when they film
indoors they refrigerate the set meaning
they turned the air-conditioning way up
so just imagine standing around on a
film set freezing your ass off for 12
hours so I think this version of the
costume is meant to look really cool
invoke a couple different versions of
killer frost in the comics and also be a
little forgiving to the actress danielle
Panabaker but i like the way they've
incorporated the star into the zipper
here and if you guys didn't see they
have already released the synopsis for
the killer frost episode episode 7
that's like when she's supposed to go
full-blown killer frost but we might not
see her in the costume until the second
half of the season or maybe like the
mid-season finale but there's a lot of
jumps between where Kaitlin
is right now before she goes full-blown
killer frost but it'll be one of those
situations I think when she does
something bad for the right reasons and
the team still tries to save her in the
end so they'll get to do like the really
cool killer frost stuff like we'll get a
really badass comic-book killer frost
but they'll do it without completely
throwing caitlin snow like the caitlin
snow that we know under the bus like
they'll be able to save her by the end
of the season what you know whatever it
is they need to do to bring her back but
I think a lot of that twist gets into
the duality of the season with what dr.
alchemy is doing in the twist with his
character so it'll all start to make
sense
together once they start to reveal big
plot points in the next couple of
episodes so just a reminder there is no
new episode tonight it's back next week
but they're still arrow they're still
legends of tomorrow so almost everything
this week will be normal with the
exception of the flash and agents of
shield agents of shield is also on break
for a couple weeks but also really cool
haven't talked about the vibe costume
yet so when episode 2 Cisco said he
might make a costume eventually like
yeah maybe but we saw his gauntlets he'd
been working on them so we knew it was
gonna happen eventually this actually
looks pretty close to his comic book
costume especially with the way they use
the colors you can definitely tell that
is sad as Cisco was at the beginning of
the season it seems like he's turned a
corner because this seems just like
something that he would be super happy
to do but the question is is if this is
gonna happen before the big 4 night
crossover because I think that's gonna
be like a big comic book action event
series like crisis on Infinite Earths
I mean it's based on the invasion
storyline in the comics but because it's
so comic book II they also want to make
the characters look very comic book E as
in wearing comic book costumes so I
don't know about the timing on the
killer frost costume but it does seem
like we might get some vibe costume
during that big four night crossover but
let me know when do you think they're
gonna debut the actual killer frost
costume will it be in the four night
crossover the mid-season finale or do
you think it's gonna be during the
second half of the season but just to be
clear danielle Panabaker is still a main
cast member on the flash so no matter
what happens with her she'll still be in
most of the episodes so it's not going
to be like
captain cold situation where they do
something crazy and then they go away
for a couple episodes there might be
like one or two episodes that she's not
in a lot of but she'll still be in most
of the episodes regardless of what her
killer frost statuses begin hey is gonna
be awesome
I'm so happy about this Young Justice
season 3 and now we have killer frost
full-blown comic book costume so the
rest of the year is gonna be awesome
really every TV show is building to the
mid-season finale so it's just gonna get
crazier and crazier no matter what show
you're watching so Ghost Rider on agents
of shield is gonna go nuts the flash is
going nuts with Savitt our dr. alchemy 4
night crossover Supergirl is doing
cyborg Superman I'm definitely gonna do
a video for that soon but what's gonna
happen is is my next video will be
another Young Justice Season 3 video
then I'll do my arrow episode video
that'll be Wednesday night so be sure to
subscribe to get everything there is a
new round of the DC giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video
so all that stuff is gonna post on
Wednesday while you guys wait for that
to post you can click here for the
trailer for the next episode of the
flash and you can click here for all my
Doctor Strange Easter eggs thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight